I want to start with a question.
What would you do if you had
$250,000,000,000,000?
I'm sure there are many things you would
do with that sort of money,
but what if I told you those
$250,000,000,000,000 worth from
Zimbabwe?
Well,
that's a totally different question
because in 2015 and 250 trillion,
Zimbabwe and dollars were worth the
equivalent of one us scholar.
Yep.
You heard that?
Absolutely right.
The truth is the Zimbabwe is like
Venezuela,
but on a massive scale,
this country has suffered the worst
hyperinflation of all time.
Since more or less than year,
2000 prices were rising higher and
higher as an absolutely mind boggling
rates.
In 2008,
a piece of bread was worth 10,000
Zimbabwean dollars and name.
Are you wondering,
well,
how did it all of this happened?
Now the answer,
it's pretty simple.
One day he told his finance minister,
dude,
I don't care how you do it,
but man,
we need money.
And what did the finance minister today?
Well,
he just pressed the money printing
button like there was no tomorrow,
so in conclusion,
Zimbabwe had to get rid of their own
national currency and led to the economy
be dominated by foreign currencies,
especially the American dollar.
All of this was a little while ago.
So what exactly is going on in Zimbabwe
now?
Well,
in recent days,
and we're recording this in 2017,
the country appeared on the news because
of Acute Atar that spells the end of
mcgarvey 37 year long dictatorship.
And yes,
my difference of visual politic,
we must say that Cuda tiles are not what
they used to be.
This was what we could call the direct
version of acute.
It's,
ah,
just have a look at.
Yes,
bobby,
to get $10,000,000 payoff and immunity
for his family and this sort of thing
better described as a soap opera.
Regard it as 93 years old wanted to
dominion power and he also wanted his
wife who's 52 years old to inherit the
presidency.
You know,
this sort of thing that can only happen
in countries like Argentina and North
Korea or perhaps the national front in
France.
So as you can imagine,
a lot of people did not agree with this.
So the IRB clans sent all of them and
physical opponents out of the country.
This is what happened in the beginning
of November 2017 when they kicked out
the vice presidents and this guy has a
really difficult to pronounce his name.
I looked it up.
I still can't pronounce it properly,
but his name is Emerson Minim,
Guam.
So yes,
sorry if I butcher the pronunciation of
his name in this one,
the army's reaction to this was
immediate and well,
you probably know the rest of the story,
but now the is about Zimbabwe's future
of many is managua.
The new mcgarvey is this man Abel to
resurrect Zimbabwe's.
Yeah.
Economy.
Well,
we are going to answer those questions,
but we do.
Let's take a look back at the history.
Thousand defect.
Yes,
you Zimbabwe's economy is a total
disaster.
I know what you're thinking.
If you make a cocktail where you mix
dictatorship and Africa,
what you guess is corruption and policy,
right?
Yeah,
kinds of right,
but probably not as much as you might
think.
In fact,
there was a time where Zimbabwe was
known as the African Jew that that's
also allowed this country to become was
a whole continents bond and now you
might be wondering,
well,
what happens when a country with so many
natural resources,
so many rich lands,
so many gold mines.
What caused it to become such a
catastrophe?
Well,
we owned that.
It definitely has a name and that name
is Robert Magaldi.
Zimbabwe has been an independent country
for some 37 years.
Thirty seven years is the amount of time
that the Gabi has been empowered.
The decolonial colonialization process
of the so called itself Rhodesia British
colony,
and that in a 15 years old
for war
I'm hands,
we had the white minority that made up
just five percent of the population.
Despite what you might think.
They didn't have the support of western
powers.
They declared their independence
unilaterally and therefore no other
countries supported them.
On the other hand,
you have the guerrilla troops led by
Robin [inaudible],
the man who combined anti imperialist
nationalism with a hardcore communist
you.
Back then,
Margaret Thatcher was the prime minister
and you might now be thinking cold war
plastic communist leader plus longer.
It sounds like a pretty explosive
combination,
right?
Well,
oh,
absolutely wrong.
Back then the UK,
his priority was to let that former
colonies become healthy democracies,
and this is why I thought Joe has self
signed,
the peace agreements with the Zimbabwe
and guerrilla fighters and organized
elections in the country.
These elections were as fast as they
could be given that the country had just
ended a civil war and had good real
warriors all over the place.
Who won the election?
Well,
of course it's rather than Garvey.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
did macaby cheats in the selection or
was it a fair victory?
Well,
the evidence actually suggests that yes,
he had the support in.
Yes,
he did genuinely
see among the majority of the black
population in Zimbabwe,
there are two major ethnic groups who
make up 80 percent of the population.
And then you have the mat of billy who
had just 10 percent rather than the Gabi
belongs to the owner group.
And this is why it's no surprise that he
wants 60 percent of the votes.
So in 1980,
the UK granted independence to Rhodesia
and this is how Zimbabwe became a
sovereign country with new Gabi as the
presidents during the first seven years,
he basically grabbed all of the power
and in terms of the economy,
at least we've got to admit that things
actually work.
So
in the beginning they'll be
respected the property rights of the
white population,
both in a very Venezuelan fashion.
He spends all of the savings from the
colonial times where we have to admit
that although it didn't work in the long
run regarding,
did achieve a greater goal and his role
is in Bob way achieved the highest
literacy rate in Africa.
Ninety percent of Zimbabweans can read
and write.
So if you've got your dictatorial to do
list in front of you,
well what's the next thing on that?
Well,
that's to get rid of the opposition in
this chapter of his life.
He did not save a penny.
He sends the fifth garrison of his army
to North Korea so that he could learn
about state of the art methods for
oppression,
and when those soldiers came back,
he pretty much said to them,
alright guys,
now go get rid of these now to bally's
wiped them out.
This is how the [inaudible] started.
Greco Hindi means in the language early
rain,
the cleans the straws by the inside
before the spring rain comes.
Yup.
Shown as they are pretty poetic,
despite the printed name.
This was an ethnic cleansing that was
done pretty much as the manual describes
and the more than 20,000 people died,
and with this regarding gained a great
deal of political stability.
Forehead killed all of his political
foes.
That's in the year 2000 things.
They really changed,
not yet decided to start an agricultural
revolution.
And the style of Chairman Mao,
it was a real revolution and everything
changed for the West.
Gabi decided that the best lands
shouldn't be owned by the white
minority.
So we,
he expropriated that land and gave it to
surprise surprise his ministers and
political allies.
However,
he only gave them the lines he could not
give them the knowledge to,
tends it,
so production fell sharply while
hyperinflation destroyed the rest of the
industries.
Since then,
Zimbabwe has pretty much been a living
hell.
Time of the crocodiles,
crocodiles wait beneath the water just
showing their eyes and their nostrils
until the victim appears.
Then they open their doors and they eat
them.
This is why the new president of
Zimbabwe,
men,
Angola,
is known as the Crocodile Mountain.
Galois was one of those leaders during
the civil war and he has been a minister
since 1980,
so he spent all of his life waiting
under the shadow of the dictator.
That moment has finally come so far
after this cue,
his first steps,
they've been very risky.
Here is an example,
Bob Wade,
leaders cabinet heavy on military ruling
party,
but this is not enough as in Bob Way and
he still has a lot of work.
It has been one of the biggest steps,
has already been taken
government a bent in digitization law
with the indigenization law is another
economic policy made by Magog.
In this case,
he said bigger companies couldn't belong
to white people.
As you can imagine,
the white minority that used to live in
the country has already integrated.
They used to be five percent of the
population.
They are now just one set,
but now the crocodile wants foreign
investments and rejecting because of his
race,
doesn't seem like a brilliant economic
idea.
Wait just a minute,
because despite all of that,
so the new president of Zimbabwe might
not be the right man for the job.
In a country like this,
it's easy to find dark spots on a
politician who served such a crazy
dictator.
And guess what crocodile did in the 19
eighties?
Yes.
He was the minister of national
security.
So he would have had something to do
with that genocide that we mentioned
earlier,
and being the person who executed the
genocide doesn't exactly make you a
prime person to run a country.
So the question is,
that probably pops into your mind right
now is really someone who can become a
true opposition to this regime,
and the answer is absolutely yes.
In 2008,
there was a political party called
Movement for Democratic Change,
and surprisingly they beat me in those
elections.
Yes,
you totally had that.
Right,
and in a dictatorship like Zimbabwe,
this meant a big time political crisis
and we've all been simply couldn't
destroy a political opponents.
You had such political capital.
On the other hand,
he also couldn't let him win and finally
regard,
but he came up with a solution.
He would remain the presidents,
but he would let his opponents,
Morgan Stanley,
right?
They come to the prime minister.
Of course,
this prime minister remained in power,
but just four years,
and during those four years,
this Bob way started using the US dollar
as an official currency after the
collapse of that local one,
but becomes free.
It still remains in dire straits
ways.
Unemployment rate at 90 percent.
This is why it's finger.
Ryan has lost a lot of political
capital,
so it does seem that in the next
election the crocodile has all of the
chances to win besides the army is also
going to control the process and the
army sports,
the crocodile.
One thing must be sad here and that is
whoever leads this country next,
we'll have a great advantage for it is
impossible to do a worse job than their
predecessors.
So now the question becomes,
do you think the crocodile will be able
to take Zimbabwe back and make it an
African jewel once again,
or do you think he's going to turn into
the next Mugabi?
Well,
please let us know your answer in the
comments section below and if you want
to know about another African dictator,
click on this video to learn about the
history of Egypt.
Do visit our friends,
have reconsidered media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this video
that we're not mine and do not forget to
hit that subscribe button.
It's captured brand new videos every
week,
and if you liked this video,
hit that thumbs up button and as always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
don't forget to check out,
reconsider podcast@reconsidermedia.com.
We consider as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context.
But we don't do the thinking.